well I am NOT the first person to say
this and I know I won't be the last but
let me just throw my endorsement behind
those people who over the course of
history have come out to condemn anyone
who jogs around the neighborhood on
Thanksgiving weekend I I just find it to
be an outrageous and offensive thing to
do you see like many families we have
essentially in my family we have like
three or four Thanksgiving it's not just
one Thanksgiving meal you've got it's
like we have three or four because we
have our we do Thanksgiving new to
Thanksgiving dinner on Thanksgiving with
my wife's side of the family and then we
do a big Thanksgiving dinner with my
side of the family on Saturday and then
in between that you know on Friday and
then also on Sunday you're eating the
the leftovers you're having the pie and
it's a holiday so you're having beer at
like 1:00 in the afternoon and by the
end of it you just you stumble outside
of your house obese and rotund and
lethargic your your stomach just full of
turkey grease and then what do you see
you see that guy
jogging spritely down the the sidewalk
showboating you know making the rest of
us feel bad about ourselves and I just
think I I feel like like everyone owes I
think ties up well that should be
illegal and it should be there should be
when I am dictator of the of the country
it will be you are not allowed to jog
from Thursday Thanksgiving morning until
at least the following Wednesday there
is no public jogging allowed because it
makes the rest of us feel bad about
ourselves and you have to think about
how other people feel okay it's just
it's just simple compassion all right
so a few things I want to get into as we
as we get back into the week after the
hope you had a great holiday by the way
video surfaced online this weekend of
the chaos down south down at the border
as people from the so-called migrant
Caravan are trying to bum rush the
border and invade the country illegally
and reportedly border agents shot tear
gas
on a couple occasions at some of the
illegal invaders and also there were
rocks being thrown at the border agents
now liberals of course have been making
this they've been making much of the
chaos and blaming it on the US and
saying how terrible it all is but listen
these are people deliberately attempting
to break our laws and push their way
into the country this is a this is
really a national security issue you
can't obviously you can't have just a
mob of people run across the border even
as there are border agents there saying
no stop and this is this is one of those
things that if it was if it was in any
other situation with any other country
there would be no question about it you
know nobody would be complaining so like
imagine if I were if I were imagine if
it were China okay imagine if I showed
up at a Chinese custom post and I tried
to run past it not listening to their
instructions to stop and I just tried to
bum-rush and run past them well I think
I could expect tear gas at the very
least and probably they would be using
methods that are quite a bit more
aggressive than teargas and nobody would
feel sorry for me one day everybody
would say well what in the world were
you thinking you can't just run into
China without they've got a procedures
in a process in play you can't just run
past them why would you even think that
you could do that they would blame me
if it were me tried to get into China I
would be blamed for it they would victim
blame me yet we're held to a different
and extremely ridiculous standard now
one other point about this there are
some children who have been mixed up in
the chaos and now the government is
being is being accused of tear gassing
children well I think first of all the
vast majority of them of the migrants
the so-called migrants and the caravan
are not children these are grown men but
as for the children there are some
children I mean you can look at the
photographs and see it for yourself and
I feel sorry for the kids I am
sympathetic to them but
fault is it that these kids are mixed up
in this parents who choose to take their
children and who force their children to
accompany them as they go on this
dangerous journey and they break our
laws and they try to get into our
country in this dangerous and illegal
way you know they're the ones at fault
so I feel bad for the kids but who do
you blame you blame the parents or the
adults who are putting the kid's in this
situation if you have kids that's all
the more reason to try to enter the
country legally in an orderly fashion
and not as part of some giant mob so we
have to remember who's that who's who's
- who we should blame in that situation
the government is doing its job it needs
to probably have a border they need to
be protected and there is a procedure to
come into this country if you're not
gonna follow the procedure then you
can't we're not just gonna let you in
alright something else that was
interesting over the weekend a well this
this starts last week a feminist was
banned apparently permanently it looks
like from Twitter for repeatedly making
the bold and outrageous claim that men
are not women she is she's one of the
rare and I think rather brave feminists
which is why she's rare it's rare to
have a real an actual brave feminist in
America anyway but she's one of the rare
ones who has stood against the whole
idea of transgenderism she believes that
men are invading appropriating
cheapening womanhood and she's
absolutely right of course but she got
banned and and Twitter has now Twitter
has now instituted some new rules it has
declared that defending biological
science is a prohibited offense on their
platform Twitter now says that if you
harass a transgender person by simply
asserting scientific reality that's what
harassment is now then you can be kicked
off the platform you're not allowed to
question transgenderism on Twitter
anymore that's the that's the new rule
so what
I do well last night I went on Twitter
and I questioned transgenderism and I
still haven't been kicked off for it but
we'll see but here's what I did rather
than simply arguing my case as I've
argued a million times that men are men
and women are women which is again a
banned statement on Twitter I figured
that rather than simply do that I
figured that I give the other side of
this debate a chance to explain
themselves because if it's true that a
man can actually be a woman and if that
fact is so self-evident and so obvious
that anyone who doubts it deserves to be
shunned from polite society and clip
kicked off of social media platforms and
so on that in that case it should be
really easy for someone to hold who
holds that view who holds the pro
transgender view it should be really
easy for them to answer some basic
questions about it right so this is the
the tweet that I sent last night I said
I invite anyone on Twitter to explain in
clear and specific detail how precisely
a biological male can come to know that
he is really a woman how does he arrive
at this conclusion on what basis with
what evidence to support it again I
invite anyone to explain thank you now
this really is the fundamental question
isn't it you have biological men who at
some point come to realize realize that
or or know or understand or whatever
that that they are really women okay so
how does that work exactly I would think
that this question should be really easy
to answer if you believe that
transgenderism is an actual thing like
it's really possible for a man to to in
some sense be a woman and to come to
that realization and then I would think
it'd be really easy to explain shouldn't
it
and if
fact this point of view is not
anti-science then again you should be
able to explain it scientifically yet I
posed this question it's a fair question
not a trick question and hours went by
without anyone even trying to answer it
instead you had liberals just telling me
that I was a bigot for even asking the
question to begin with but finally some
people did attempt something like an
answer I want to go through some of the
answers to to my question now so that we
can yeah I mean look don't take my word
for it
I think it seems to me that the leftist
position on transgenderism is is
nonsensical and inexplicable they they
can't explain it it's just a it's a
faith-based view but as I said don't
take my word for it let's let's take a
look at their answers and you tell me if
these answers make sense so we'll go
through a few of them here Laura said I
invite you to provide scientific
evidence to prove the existence of God
other than the Bible how do you know God
exists well that's not an answer
obviously that that just avoids the
question entirely and actually
ironically it proves my point this this
person seems to be admitting that
transgenderism is an item of faith not a
scientifically observable fact also for
the record I can provide scientific
evidence for God that has nothing to do
with the Bible the formation of life
from inanimate matter the existence of
consciousness the first cause etc all of
these are legitimate scientific
evidences for God and and there are none
quite so compelling for transgenderism
susan says why do you care I don't
understand it but I respect people and
respect the decisions they make about
their own lives and bodies that's all
you have to do again that's not an
answer I'm not and I'm not the one
insisting that people care you know when
when Twitter says that you you know
you're not allowed to simply say that
men are men and women are women
well then that's Twitter insisting that
we care about this about the
transgenderism thing they're the ones
insisting on it
and this has been this is one of the
tried-and-true tactics of the left it
has been for decades where they take
something like transgenderism they shove
it in your face 24/7 they insist that
you adopt their perspective on it they
insist that your children adopt their
perspective on it they insist that laws
be changed according to their
perspective on it and then when you
resist or when you even ask a question
about it when you even say hey wait a
second why should we even when you even
so much as do that they'll say why do
you care so much it's none of your
business why do you care I care because
you demand that I care so you're getting
what you want here let's see what other
answers do we have someone who goes by
the Twitter handle resister said if
someone finds that they naturally think
feel act and perceive the world in a
certain way that's what makes a person
who they are there is no deeper what you
really are
that determines gender that's it okay
now we get to something that
approximates or attempts an answer but
it's not a good answer here we are told
that a biological man might think feel
act and perceive like a woman and
therefore be a woman okay but how
a biological man no that what he's
thinking and feeling is how could he
know that he's thinking and feeling like
a woman how could he know what that even
means because he isn't one so it's
circular okay so I ask you how does he
know he's a woman and you say well
because it feels like one and I say well
how does he know that he feels like one
and you say because he is one well how
does he know that he is one because he
feels like one and on and on and on into
infinity the fact is a man cannot feel
like a woman because he isn't a woman he
has no frame of reference a man has no
possible way of knowing that his
feelings are the feelings of a woman
there is no way to know that because a
feeling isn't in is an interior
emotional private thing that happens
within a person and so you cannot you
just you just couldn't possibly know it
and besides what does it even mean to
feel like a woman
what is a female thought what is a
female feeling now I of course I'm not a
woman again side but I think it's I
assumed I it stands to reason that women
being people you know are are similar to
me and so I know for in the sense that
for me I have many different feelings
many different thoughts a whole wide
range of feelings and thoughts and I
believe women are the same way right so
how can you seize on any one particular
feeling or thought and say well that's
how a woman feels and things a woman
feels and thinks a million different
things because she's a person so it
doesn't even make any sense
so that's not a good answer that's a bad
answer another answer says I am FTM
female-to-male so I can answer how a
biological female can think they're a
boy according to my mom at age four I
said things would be when things would
make so much more sense if I could be a
boy at age 13 when she gave the talk I
asked her when my body would start
producing semen my parents are very
conservative Christians it has nothing
to do with how I was raised
they did not encourage it I didn't
transition until I was 22 I honestly
think it's a brain and body mismatch
that were born with that's just me
though okay well here we have the same
sort of problem a four year old girl
says that it makes more sense if she
were a boy but what does a four-year-old
girl know about being a boy you know
that is one of the one of the great many
problems with these parents who say well
I you know I knew that my my son was
really a girl from the age of three
because he was saying that he was a girl
well a three year old or a four year old
has no idea what those words mean okay a
four year old girl has no concept of
what a boy is except for the most sort
of innocent and and and shallow kind of
perception of it and so you know I'll
tell you a four-year-old girl when she
thinks of what is a boy the first thing
she's thinking of is okay well boys like
to play with toy trains and boys like to
go running around and roll around in the
mud boys like to play football you know
that's what that's what a child is
thinking when a when a when a child when
a young girl thinks of what constitutes
a boy that's what she means so when a
four-year-old girl says I wish I were a
boy what she means is I'd like to play
with toy trains and I'd like to go play
catch outside that's what she needs
so okay get her the toy trains
let her go play catch let her go roll
around in the mud so what
that perfectly fine she's a child it
cannot have any deeper meaning because
she as a child does not have a deeper
understanding of what it means to be a
boy or a girl by the way a four year old
girl has has very little concept of
herself let alone of anyone else she's a
child four years ago she didn't exist
she's only four years into existence
she's she's very new to it she doesn't
have a concept of it um as for the
question at age thirteen this again just
shows confusion so you have a
thirteen-year-old girl saying when do I
produce semen well that this is a girl
who's confused she doesn't understand
what a girl is she doesn't she doesn't
even understand what a girl is she
doesn't know who she is
as a girl how could she make the choice
how could she reject being a girl and
come to the conclusion that she's not
one when she clearly doesn't even know
what one is it seems that a lot of
parents these days they they make the
mistake of confusing confusion with
knowledge so they find that their child
is confused about certain biological
basic biological facts and they
interpret that as oh well my child must
know something
maybe my child must have some deeper
insight that I'm just not privy to no
they don't your kid is just confused
that's all your child needs
clarification your child needs help
answer ironically the twitter handle is
biased towards reality and they said if
you want to know you'd ask an expert in
the field not Twitter but gender is a
spectrum of preferences not a thing
between your legs some humans with
penises diverge so far from what we call
male preferences that they identify more
with what we for refer to as female
ok well but according to this a
transgender woman in that case is simply
a man who prefers certain things that
society typically associates with women
fine but in that case a transgender
woman is in no sense whatsoever a woman
he's simply a less masculine man that's
all if that's what you're telling is ok
well they just though it's a man who
prefers things that society associated
with oh well fine ok then that is a
feminine man but in that case to call
him a woman to change the pronouns at
all of that that makes no sense
whatsoever also by the way you're only
reinforcing gender roles here because
for the last 50 years we've been told
that preferences and tastes and opinions
and and all of that we've been told that
none of that has anything to do with
gender we've been told that there is no
such thing as a female taste or a female
opinion that just because you're a woman
doesn't mean that you should wear
dresses it doesn't mean that you should
prefer any particular colour or hobby or
anything that's what we've been told
that was the whole idea here I thought
the whole idea was to was to basically
abolish the this notion of gender they
say that gender is a social construct
and it basically it tells us what
society associates with men and women
and so for the last 50 years what
Liberals have been saying is well let's
get rid of genders you know men can do
whatever they want women can do whatever
they want but now they have abandoned
that position and they have gone way to
the other end of the of the of the
argument and now they're saying that
that that in fact not only do female
preferences and female opinions and
tastes exist but they are so ingrained
that if a man has a female taste or
opinion or preference then he must
actually be a woman so do you see how
the Liberals have gone from they've gone
from deconstructing the gender paradigm
to actually reinforcing it and and
reinforcing it in a way that is far
stricter than how it was before because
you know a hundred years ago you would
have more feminine men and more
masculine women that existed a hundred
years ago now maybe they were frowned
upon by society or whatever but but they
still existed now what we're saying is
they can't exist that if you're a
feminine man then actually you're a
woman because femininity is so tied to
womanhood that if you experience it as a
man then you become a woman and vice
versa
so we see here that transgenderism is an
indefensible proposition it is an
indefensible self-contradicting
proposition it is a it is a belief that
cannot be explained I mean these were
the attempts to explain it and as you
can tell they're just they fail they
fail in really obvious clear ways so
it's just a
matter of faith that's all it's a is a
it is a faith-based religious conviction
where somebody believes with no
scientific reason whatsoever they just
believe based on their own opinions in
their own religious convictions that a
man can really be a woman or a woman can
really be a man and all I'm saying is
look you're entitled to your religious
beliefs you're entitled to your
faith-based beliefs I'd be the first one
to say that but at least admit that
that's what they are that's all I'm
saying all right one other thing I
wanted to touch on here and this is a
huge surprise
last week I gave an opinion that people
didn't like I know that you'll have to
collect yourself and recuperate after
hearing the shocking news there but yeah
people didn't like something that I said
I said on my show and on Twitter that I
don't agree with the whole concept of
uncontacted tribes and the reason why
this came up is because of a story last
week where a missionary tried to make
contact with a tribe on an island off
the coast of I think India and and they
were and he was brutally murdered by
them in the process he was simply trying
to make contact with them and this tribe
like several other tribes around the
globe has essentially been placed in a
protective cocoon by its government
there they're living a thousand years in
the past and nobody is allowed to go
there and sort of ruin the illusion
nobody's allowed to go and even speak to
them now my point is that this system is
lunacy we are we are basically
preserving people like museum exhibits
or like zoo animals and I think it's
dehumanizing and it's ridiculous
a lot of people disagreed with my point
apparently and over the weekend hundreds
of people were expressing their outrage
at me online I wasn't online at all over
the weekend because it was a holiday so
I didn't see any of this and I only
became aware of the reaction last night
when I got a few emails from some other
websites and media outlets asking me
about the backlash and what my reaction
is to it I didn't even know there was a
backlash which by the way is a nice
lesson for all of us because all I had
to do was just not pick up my phone and
it was as if the outrage wasn't
happening
it didn't matter it doesn't matter all
you have to do is is not go online and
you become like an uncontacted tribe of
one impervious to the pitchfork mob
that's why the you know the these these
online pitchfork mobs they don't matter
all you have to do is just put this
thing down and they're not there you
just live your life who cares and that's
kind of a wonderful thing that you could
have hundreds of people furiously
writing emails and and tweeting you and
I'm so angry and it just doesn't I don't
care it doesn't matter it's it's it's
all just contained in this thing it
doesn't matter at all but since I'm
since I'm back now I thought I'd
elaborate on my point and try to make it
more clear
and my points
was not that these tribes should be
forcibly assimilated it wasn't that we
should go and steal their land my point
wasn't that we should enslave them or
exploit them or abused them in any way
at all my point was not any of those
like I could go on for literally a
million years listing all of the points
I didn't make because I didn't make all
of the potential points in the world I
did not I only made one point there are
trillions of points I did not make I
only made one I simply questioned the
idea that it should be illegal to go and
speak to a group of people okay I
questioned the invisible force field
that's placed around these tribes so
that they won't even be aware of the
outside world and yeah perhaps a few of
the tribe members are somewhat sort of
aware but most of the children raised
inside the force field will not be aware
of the outside world they won't even
know that it exists they are being
consigned to this primitive existence
and are not being given the choice of
leaving and living like the rest of us
of course they aren't given a choice
that's the whole point to give them a
real choice between living like that or
living differently they'd have to
actually be significantly exposed to the
realities of the outside world like all
the rest of us are but they aren't so
they're not given a choice
you have generations that are raised in
this bubble that the government has
created and enforced and they they're
just consumed no option they're just
it's just their that's just how they're
gonna live they don't have a choice I
think that's crazy
I think it's wrong and it may sound
really wonderful to you but tell me is
it wonderful to die when you're 25
because your teeth are rotting out of
your head and the infection has spread
to your lungs and now it's killing you
is it is it is it wonderful to die of
diseases that that we could cure with
antibiotics in three days is it
wonderful to live without refrigeration
is it wonderful to be unaware of the
existence of germs is it wonderful to
get horribly sick because you don't know
you're supposed to wash your hands after
you use the bathroom um the people have
a right to live that way if they want to
but they should know that there is
another option with these things and
children should know
there are
I mean just that last thing alone about
about germs like
that alone is enough reason I think to
to do away with this ridiculous idea of
uncontacted truck I mean these are
people that they don't know about germs
do you have any idea do you have any
idea what it's like to live not knowing
that germs exist do you have any idea
how many people died horribly and young
simply because they don't know they're
supposed to wash their hands and the
government sets this cocoon nobody's
allowed to go tell them you're not
allowed to go tell them hey by the way
look live how you want but just germs
exist or these you know these little
tiny microscopic things that make you
sick just wash your head you're not
allowed to go tell them that you can't
tell them and so they're just going to
keep dying there are a lot of
actively good things in modern society
that because of this force field these
kids that live in these tribes as they
grow into adults will never get a chance
to benefit from and I think that that is
wrong
now if you
disagree perhaps I can make my point by
way of analogy let's think about the
Amish okay
the Amish choose
and they really do choose to mostly
reject modern society and to live in a
in a unique way a way that's unique in
2018 but would not have been unique in
1818 which is the point and that's fine
they want to live that way I totally
respect it completely respect and it
really is a choice because the Amish
know that that that the rest of the
world is out there and the point is they
reject modern society but they know what
they're rejecting
so they can make an informed choice
but let's imagine something for a moment
let's say that the Amish decided that
they're losing way too many people that
with the way that they live their kids
are still very much exposed to the
outside world they're aware of it and so
many of them as they get older decide to
leave and live in a more modern way so
let's say the Amish decide that they
want to solve that problem so they want
to be uncontacted and they have their
plot of land in rural Pennsylvania and
it is their land after all and and they
want to be uncontacted you aren't
allowed to go talk to them you're not
allowed to make any kind of contact with
them whatsoever and if you do they might
literally kill you and let's say the US
government goes along with this and they
declare that the Amish are now an
uncontacted truck meaning it would be
illegal for you to go and make any sort
of contact with them whatsoever and
again they're doing this so that their
ancient way of living can be preserved
without the slightest possibility of any
outside influence and without giving the
next generation a chance to choose
between living that way or living some
other way would you be in favor of that
would you be in favor of a designation
of the Amish as an uncontacted tribe
where it is now illegal to speak to them
would you think that such a system is
fair or humane or rational or would you
say that the Amish should not be placed
in a cocoon where modern civilization is
artificially withheld would you say that
such a system is crazy because it
exempts the Amish from the realities of
living in a human civilization and it
exempts them in a way that none of the
rest of us are exempt
I can't declare myself uncontacted we're
like you're not even allowed to knock on
my door
and would you say that it's unfair to
their children because it makes it
impossible for the next generation to
make an informed choice about how they
want to live I think we all know we all
know what we would say in the case of
the Amish well why would an uncontacted
tribe in a jungle be any different it's
the same idea and it's wrong for the
same reasons
I'm not saying they can't choose that
anyone can choose to live however they
want but what what I am raising an issue
with is the imaginary force field that's
put around them by the government where
they are not even allowed to be
introduced to the realities of modern
society
even the really positive good
life-affirming life preserving realities
like medicine and refrigeration and
hygiene like they're not even allowed to
know about any of that now there are
those who say that it's you know doing
the whole uncontacted thing it's totally
worth it
even if it means that their children are
going to die young and that they're
gonna suffer miseries that are totally
unnecessary it's totally worth it though
because it preserves their culture and
it would be a great shame if their
culture was destroyed by exposure to the
outside world
well why though why do we need to
preserve a tribal culture that has its
that has held itself in isolation and
exactly as it has it's always been since
the Year 25 BC I mean what why does that
need to be preserved what what would it
why would it be a great tragedy if that
tribe were to in some sense is
modernized and start to take advantage
of some of these great things that I
mentioned that we have am i why would
that be it what would be so terrible
about that like is it it would it
somehow is it does it somehow detract
from from the the great diversity of
planet Earth if if this tribe were to
you know have electricity and have a
telephones like what's wrong with that
and would anyone say that European or
American culture of 1810 or you know
1790 should be preserved exactly intact
as it's always as it was back then
does anyone bolon the fact that our own
culture has developed so much over the
last 300 years
no in fact most people would say that
it's good that our old ancient culture
is gone and has changed because because
that culture included the dehumanization
of black people and the subjugation of
women
so again in any other case with any
other group we do not mourn the fact
that cultures change over time and over
the centuries we consider it good we
consider it a necessity
but in this case with these tribes we
say no it must remain exactly as it's
always been
for the last 3,000 years and if it grows
or matures or changes or develops at all
that is some great tragedy why it
doesn't make I mean just when you really
stop and think about it that simply
doesn't make any sense at all
it really doesn't
um Oh No
tribe learns about washing their hands
that's a tragedy we can't we can't allow
that do you realize how you're treating
them again you're treating them like zoo
and you're treating them like like a an
exhibit you're not treating them like
human beings you're not
because
there were any other human
in any other situation and they were
living this really tough
short painful existence because they
didn't know about some of these basic
realities of mana you would tell them
about it if it were anyone if it were
your neighbor who somehow been living in
a cave or something and didn't know
about that you tell him about it
wouldn't you
finally
one thing that your people's one thing
people said when they were challenging
my view is that I seem to be implying
that modern that our culture modern
culture Western culture is superior to
that of these primitive tribes and I was
told that you know that's a that's a
terrible terrible thing to say
well yeah guilty as charged our culture
is of course superior now that doesn't
mean that we are superior as individuals
it doesn't mean that they're less human
it doesn't mean that they should be
killed or enslaved or deprived of their
land or anything like that it just it
just means that our culture is obviously
better than theirs I mean all cultures
are not equal it is possible to have
cultures that are not as good as other
cultures our culture is more advanced
technologically philosophically
politically and in every quantifiable
way so yes it's a it is better if it has
contributed more to the world that has
accomplished greater things so on and so
on and so on the fact that I even have
to explain this and defend it just shows
that most most of what makes our culture
better has nothing to do with us
individually so understand that when I
say this this is not an egotistical or
an arrogant thing I I don't get any of
the credit for the fact that our culture
is better than some of these other
cultures you don't get any credit for
that
we are actually in the process of
squandering all of these superior
aspects of our culture they were given
to us by those who came before us
we have we have added of you know a few
positive innovations I suppose but we
didn't come up with any of the basics
and now a lot of it is slipping away
because we're too stupid and befuddled
to actually Charis and protect the great
civilization that was handed to us so
this is not about we as individuals or
better anything like that and as I said
I am a huge critic of modern society and
modern people myself included we have a
lot of flaws but there are also a lot of
things again many of those things that
were given already that were handed to
us given to us there are a lot of things
that just that just make our culture a
better place to live and just better
across the board
and that's
to share those things with other people
not forcibly not at the point of a gun
but just to share them that's all and
anyone should be should be kept in a
bubble so that these things can you know
are not shared with them I don't think
that's fair to them and to their kids so
that's my case and again I'll just say
if you disagree with me just just to be
clear what you're saying is that it is
worth all of you know it's it
essentially what you're saying is
tribes are uncontacted they're not told
about the outside world yes that means
that they're going to die in these
horrible ways where they in ways that
they do not need to and they're going to
suffer in ways that they do not need to
but all of that is worth it you're
saying that is all worth it because of
whatever benefits exist in not
contacting
I just I find that opinion to be really
extreme and radical and bizarre and
frankly and I and I disagree with it
alright we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed